Paris Hilton teases her return to music  [Music]  on Tuesday night the 36 year old  socialite shared a snippet of her  upcoming song summer rain on social  media  [Music]  and get this the single coincides with  the debut of her 23rd fragrance Rose a  rush Paris hasn't released new music  since her 2015 song high off my love  featured Birdman  [Applause]  which made it onto billboards top ten  Dance Club Songs chart  Paris posted the new sneak peak to  Instagram writing that she is quote so  proud but that's not all Paris has to be  proud of in May The Simple Life star and  her boyfriend chris Zylka told ET that  they're happy in love you wake up with a  smile and you fall asleep with a smile  being best friends I'm finally finding  someone that I love and trust and know  that I want to spend the rest of my life  with it's the best feeling in the world  [Music]